qu'ils gagnent
[Musique]
ce qu'ils reprochent à leur présidence
c'est vraiment cette très mauvaise
gestion de cette crise e le départ des
troupes américaines
devait se faire de manière ordonnée et
de manière sécurisée et c'est pas du
tout ce qui s'est passé du coup les
américains se rendent compte que leur
gouvernement ou leur président n'est pas
au courant de ce qui se passe et que ses
conseillers ne savent pas gérer une
situation rappelons que la politique
internationale c'est supposé être le
point fort de joe biden et que l'armée
américaine
c'est le symbole de sa présence et c'est
une institution en laquelle les
américains ont encore confiance est là
ils ont un président qui est aux abonnés
absents qui blâment tout le monde sauf
rien et ils ont une arme etc est
impuissant donc inévitablement ça ne
passe pas
[Musique]